my coach load up 30 diners are about to
descend on the second Indian restaurant
battling for a place in the semi-finals
of my nationwide restaurant competition
it's the brilliant in London voted for
by you in droves it has three
generations of customers and any Russian
that can boast that must be do something
absolutely spot-on lien and family have
been running this Punjabi restaurant for
forty years with Dibner Shanker and dad
Gullu at the helm this is a huge ship
and to be right amongst the best it just
encourages us more and more to do even
better these days goodies retire from
the stove leaving the brilliance kitchen
in the hands of head chef jazz all the
ingredients all the meats they're cooked
freshly piping hot served to the
customers within seconds the brilliant
is known for its Park Service I don't
want people waiting for more than five
or six minutes you walk in here you
taste the food and you really start to
believe they've earned their place as a
front runner of Indian food in this
country
boasting 220 seats 28 years in the good
food guide and over 80 awards the
brilliant is an Indian heavyweight
delicious ready good I'm about to hit
them with my first challenge like
Prashad they'll also have just two hours
to serve my 30 diners who will arrive in
order all at once it takes some balls to
call it the brilliant because you can't
be anything less than brilliant one of
my lights are nice yeah we are very
confident we've got only 30 diners we're
gonna make sure these guests have a
fantastic experience
maybe some brilliant service hi Jess yep
yeah right how's it sounding yeah what
are you thinking of having on the menu
tonight are two of the house
specialities lamb chops marinated in
nutmeg and cardamom and king prawns with
fresh herbs and lime juice both cooked
in the traditional tandoor oven two
abortions and URI lamb chops and two
Tory prawns but I'm worried HF jazz is
only using one of the kitchen to tandoor
Evans and already tandoori orders are
racking up three prongs one lamb chops
come on let's go